as a youtuber myself i also watch a lot
of youtube like
way too much actually and when i'm not
watching videos about sonic the hedgehog
or old computer games or marvel movies
i'm watching either fitness content
predictably or self-improvement
self-development content i find this
stuff pretty interesting so it's a shame
then that on the whole this stuff just
isn't for me anymore it's just not aimed
at me and if you're a parent you might
know what i'm talking about so the vast
majority of training advice and
certainly the vast majority of
self-improvement and productivity advice
is aimed squarely at 20 somethings who
are single and without children and as
you'll know if you're a parent yourself
having children makes things a little
bit different and some of the advice
just doesn't fly anymore in this video i
want to explain what's different and why
a lot of that information doesn't apply
to us in the same way i also want to
talk about how you can work around it
and still be highly productive and get
into great shape as a parent and i also
hope there'll be some information in
here that's useful for people who don't
have children yet so they can see where
we're coming from particularly content
creators but also anyone who's
interested in what's down the line for
them i want to delve into whether or not
becoming a parent is a young age is a
good idea if you have big goals and big
fitness goals so this is going to be one
of those talky videos without further
ado let's get into it
first things first allow me to defend my
hypothesis by explaining why is i think
that fitness content and
self-improvement content isn't really
aimed at parents for the most part and
the first and most glaring example of
this is sleep so many videos so many
channels probably including mine at some
point say how important it is to get
eight hours of sleep every night they're
like this is the first thing you should
do if you want to be productive or if
you want to build a muscle and it's
non-negotiable and sure that's great
advice good thing i'm a wizard then
because as a parent getting eight hours
of sleep is nigh impossible my son who's
about eight months now is actually the
best sleeper in the world like to a
extraordinary degree and he started
sleeping through from a very young age
in fact a lot of other parents hate me
for it
but even he he will wake up at five
o'clock in the morning he requires a
dream feed at 11 30 so we can't really
get to sleep that much earlier than we
would do otherwise
and then he might wake up two or three
times during the night
now i could turn over to my wife and say
sorry it's your turn again because
muscle building is biphasic but i'm not
sure that she'd really appreciate that i
have to do my bit as well which means
that i'm not gonna get eight hours of
sleep most nights i could also sleep
prior to that dream feed however i do
also want to have some life as soon as i
finish all the chores at like 9 30 p.m
i'm not gonna then go to bed only to
wake up at five that's just a miserable
life i want to have at least an hour or
two to myself to spend with my wife to
do nice things watching love island at
the moment not proud of it but i am
enjoying it point is i'm not getting
eight hours sleep a lot of other parents
are gonna get even less sleep something
that's actually really useful for
parents on a time crunch is today's
sponsor blinkist so blinkist is an app
that condenses key ideas from books and
sometimes podcasts into much smaller
much more consumable 15-minute chunks
specifically blinkist condenses
non-fiction books and it has over 5 000
titles from 27 different categories to
choose from a book i really enjoyed on
there recently was chasing excellence by
ben bergeron this is a book all about
what it takes to be an athlete at the
very highest level and how ben goes
about coaching those athletes from a
mental and a cognitive perspective in
particular he talks about thinking about
what you can control and what you can't
control and how the best athletes will
focus on what they can control he'll get
them to write a list of all the things
they can't control and to just stop
wasting time energy and anxiety on them
and one of the key things you can always
control is your response to the
situation in a moment i'll be talking
about how to cope with a loss of sleep
as a parent and instead of fretting
about the fact that you've lost sleep
because that's outside of your control
instead think about your response to
that lack of sleep how are you going to
cope moving forward and this will make
more sense in a moment the other good
examples that viewers of this channel
will enjoy are the 4-hour body by tim
ferriss and thinking fast and slow and
bioneers can get a 7-day free trial
followed by 25 of a premium membership
by going to the link in the description
down below thanks once again to blinkist
for sponsoring this video and now back
to our usual programming
which leads me on to morning routines
which is something that has been
lambasted before on youtube but morning
routines is just a concept that's
entirely foreign to any parent because
sure it'd be nice to wake up at the
crack of dawn and then meditate for a
little bit maybe read the news do a
workout etc have a cold shower eat this
perfect balanced breakfast but again as
a parent that just ain't happening first
thing i have to do in the morning when i
wake up is get my daughter ready whilst
hannah gets my son ready then i have to
make the breakfast whilst hannah gets
herself ready then we all eat breakfast
my son is eating these purees which
takes about 40 minutes of him wiping it
on his face which is very stressful i
really even start work at 9am as it is
without meditating and this idea of
being really proactive as you start your
day make sure you're in a proactive
headspace when you start your day not
reactive don't answer any emails etc
emails are not the issue here the issue
here is being shouted at by a kid who
doesn't want to do her teeth or wants to
watch more videos while she does her
teeth but then she doesn't pay attention
and she doesn't brush her teeth properly
i feel like i've done 10 rounds with
mike tyson before i've even started my
day and i'm not really in a proactive
headspace in fact i'm barely even
functioning
so morning routines are off the table
and so too are just routines in general
because any time you think you've got
into this like nice routine flow
something will come along and like blast
out the water whether that's one of the
kids getting covered for example which
means that they can't go to preschool
whether it's one of us getting poorly
and we get poorly all the time because
the kid brings home all these diseases
from preschool which makes us sick also
all tired and under asleep also my son
will actually wipe his butt and then
wipe his hand across your face in just
this big smear or maybe you need to
paint the house and normally that
wouldn't be an issue but you can't paint
the house with the kids in the house
they need to be shipped off which means
you all need to go and stay with your
in-laws and then the painted decorators
don't show up and perhaps this was an
honest mistake so then you arrange it
for another time but then the in-laws
get covered so it has to be rearranged
again and each time you have to
completely change your schedule your
your content schedule you have to
rethink about when you're going to film
it when you're going to edit it where
are you going to be when you're training
this is just a hypothetical example you
understand point is you don't get any
routine but also you are stuck rigidly
to this routine i can't just jet off to
another country and film a cool video
there even though i'd love to and if i
injure myself i can't just take some
time off to recover properly because i'm
a parent and i have to stick to this
routine and that involves being jumped
on all the time
goals are completely different and
there's this unspoken assumption in a
lot of content that you're kind of
training to attract members of the
opposite sex and particularly with
productivity and self-improvement you're
trying to attract the opposite sex
there's a whole kind of subculture of
that on youtube and as a parent as
someone who's happily married that's
obviously not my goal or my interest
anymore some information on how to build
the perfect v taper because that's what
feels like a t-shirt and looks great is
not particularly interesting to me and
the same goes i imagine for a lot of
other parents as well we just want to be
healthy and feel good about ourselves
and our goals change in terms of
productivity as well so these days i
realize i want to spend more time with
my family and
success for the sake of success isn't
really worth it i could grow this
channel a lot faster if i invested in it
more if i hired lots of people teams of
marketers etc but in doing that i then
become this kind of ceo guy i'd have a
lot more stress that i'd be responsible
for them as well as for my children and
my family i don't have a job where yeah
i'm successful and yeah i'm doing things
i enjoy but it's not taking loads of
time away from my family life or
committing me to things that i don't
necessarily want to be committed to i
don't want to be successful at the
expense of being a good dad and i think
a lot of mums and dads watching this
might hopefully feel the same way too
your priorities shift and a lot of the
youtube content out there just doesn't
reflect this
so then all this raises the question
should you even become a parent at a
young age if you're interested in
getting to your best ever shape if you
want to build a business or thrive in
some kind of other career path someone
who had an interesting perspective on
this is captain sinbad i'm a fan of his
channel i love the production value and
the way he draws on movies for
inspiration in a similar way that i do
and i feel like he's actually trying to
make art here not just youtube talking
head we're actually at a similar level
in terms of our growth he doesn't know
this but i'm secretly competing with him
because i'm a maniac but in one of his
videos he referenced the book and to
paraphrase it was basically saying that
becoming a parent at young age is one of
the worst things you can do if you want
to be successful because it takes up so
many resources so much time so much
energy and you just can't build an
empire when you're also trying to be a
parent and this is something that i
disagree with i would not advise any
single people out there to avoid
starting a family if they want to be
successful in fact quite the opposite
personally i'm actually financially far
more stable now than i ever was when i
was single and part of the reason for
this is being a parent which lights a
fire under your ass and make sure that
you really focus on what you're doing
when emmy came along that's when i
decided to launch an ebook and sell it
from the site which ultimately was a big
success more so than i expected and it's
what led to me being able to do the
bioneer as my full-time job i also did
this in a very careful way i still work
for android authority i was still a
freelance writer and i kept those things
going because i didn't want to take a
leap of faith and potentially jeopardize
the you know financial future of my
family at the same time being a parent
just grows you up and i don't want to be
one of those people who condescends to
non-parents like you can't possibly know
what it's like but it does really mature
you in some fundamental ways that are
hard to explain clearly i'm still a
man-child but at the same time i also am
much more restrained and i'd like to
think i'm more patient and more
understanding of other people a little
bit more measured in my opinions and
i've had experience being a genuine
leader which is something that anyone
can experience by being a parent it's
changed the way i approach things and
honestly i think i'm more successful
because of that growth and maturity that
i've achieved you know the first time
you get a job you grow up in a lot of
ways and you can undeniably say you've
changed between getting that job and not
having the job the same thing happens
when you become a parent you change in a
fundamental way and on the whole i think
it's for the better it forces you to
grow up in those key areas
by the way my wife always said that she
wasn't attracted to muscular men when we
first started dating so it didn't even
help me in that regard she's also very
unimpressed with like traditional
markers of success and i love her so
much for that the great thing about
being in a happy family is it takes all
this external pressure off you know i'm
not trying to impress anybody i'm happy
i don't need external validation in the
same way because i get it from my family
so it just frees you it's very
liberating and of course i should say
that having children is like absolutely
amazing they're hilarious they're
fascinating they're extremely cute and
yeah they become your best little
buddies
and the other thing is being a parent
doesn't stop you from achieving the
things that you want to achieve like
genuinely so many guys i know have ended
promising relationships because they
felt they're being held back by their
partners they want to travel the world
or start a business focus on their
career get into amazing shape
but in every single case where that's
happened that person they'd then not go
on to travel the world or to start an
amazing business they just kind of
floundered and eventually ended up in a
different relationship on the other hand
i know plenty of people who've been
highly successful and they're in
relationships in a lot of cases here the
other half and the children are useful
scapegoats for why your life isn't the
way you wanted to be i've always been of
the philosophy that if there's two
things i want and i'm forced to choose
between them my answer is always do both
and there's no reason you can't be
productive successful train hard and
raise a family and we'll get to some
tips on how to do that in a moment and
in terms of getting strong and into
shape with kids actually in some ways
you get into even better shape because
having kids means you're constantly
active constantly moving i'm being
climbed on all the time by my kids we
play a game called playground where i
have to do kettlebell swings with my
daughter she calls that the swing i have
to do leg raises for hanging onto my
legs that's the seesaw sometimes i'm
going up and down the stairs carrying
both children one on each arm my
daughter's 17 kilograms i think my son
is about eight kilograms that's a lot of
weight to be carrying all the time you
guys know how much i agree with you know
constantly training throughout the day
and in this way dad strength is very
real and very similar to farmer strength
so then how do we work around the
limitations the challenges of having
kids if you want to be productive and
get into amazing shape well my first
piece of advice in terms of getting into
shape and training is to make your
workouts more adaptable so that you can
train under a range of different
circumstances one way i've done this is
that i've written multiple versions of
the same workout so i have three
workouts that i alternate between at the
moment they're kind of based on the
protein performance system super
functional training 2.0 but i've adapted
them to my current needs and then i do a
version of those depending on where i am
so one version is suitable for the gym
which is great if i want the weights
access to more tools there's a version i
do when i'm outside if i'm going to use
my kettlebell and my
medicine ball and run around the field
somewhere then there's a version that i
do if i'm in the office because i've got
some equipment here that i train with
and there's a version i can do at home
whilst my wife is going through the
shower in the evening before bed
obviously i don't have a bench press at
home but by doing high repetition
push-ups or by doing dips i can somewhat
train in an equivalent manner and this
actually just keeps things fresh and
interesting but it also means that if i
can't get to the gym that doesn't mean
that i don't train another thing i do is
that i have essential exercises the
things i absolutely must do then i have
bonus additional peripheral exercises so
i might go to the gym and if i've only
got 25 minutes in the gym before i need
to start work then i'll do those
essential things there and that's at
least something at the same time the
peripheral exercises the one i leave at
the end they tend to be the ones that i
can do somewhere else so i might do my
big bulky workout in the morning at the
gym and then in the evening i'll finish
up with some mobility work with maybe
some handstand practice or maybe some
light push-ups and things this way i'm
spreading my workouts for the day which
you guys know is something that i highly
advocate but also i'm adapting my
training to my situation i would also
say that with regards to the routine
changing without warning you should also
always train when the opportunity arises
so don't take too many rest days if you
don't need them because you might need
them later when the boiler breaks or
something then of course i also
recommend training throughout the day
wherever possible breaking your workouts
into smaller workouts is something i've
talked about a lot on this channel one
of the reasons i do this is because i'm
a parent and it's a great way to fit it
in so i'll do a 10 minute workout here
10 minute workout there everyone has 10
minutes in the day and i made a whole
video discussing how 10 minutes in a day
can be enough to train another thing to
think about is just efficiency as in how
quickly can you get into the gym do a
workout that's going to stimulate to
growth and adaptation and get out this
is something that will come with time as
you get more practiced you'll learn
specifically what your body responds to
and how to feel when you've done enough
and get that minimum effective dose
for me the biggest issue with training
as a parent isn't that i don't have time
and it's not even that i don't have
energy i think that everyone has at
least a little bit of time if you've
watched anything on tv in the last week
you had a little bit of time the issue
is sometimes energy but the other issue
and the big one for me is that there's
so much i want to do and there's not
enough time to do all those things so
it's not that i don't want to work out
because i really enjoy working out but
it's just that there might be something
that's even more tempting like at the
moment i'm playing shenmue 3 as i've
randomly talked about a weird amount on
this channel i also install some
emulators and i'm playing the old virtue
of fighter games i really want to watch
doctor strange now it's on streaming
wife and i still haven't watched top gun
there are books i want to read comics
i've downloaded the latest iron man
comic and the latest dragon ball super
manga haven't even had a chance to read
them when it comes to the evening and
i've got 10 minutes to fit in this
workout sometimes the allure of virtua
fighter or dragon ball super is a little
bit too strong and i'd rather do that
one solution to this is multitasking
your workouts so that could mean that
you're watching tv whilst you're
training or it might just mean that
between sets you did a little bit of
reading or between sets you do a little
bit of gaming and one of the reasons i
wanted to talk about this is because so
many sites and so many youtube channels
talk about this like it's the devil like
you must focus 100 on your workouts at
all times and that's great if you have
loads of time but my ethos on this is
that training in a distracted way is
better than not training at all
as for the sleep this is something
that's a little bit harder to negotiate
some people tend to take power naps but
again i think this is advice that isn't
always that in touch with reality
personally i and my wife find that power
naps make us feel really groggy when we
wake up and if the issue is time because
they have so many chores to do because
that's the thing with kids you don't
just do they're looking after the kids
you have to make all those weird purees
for them and you have to clean up the 10
times as much crockery because you know
you have more mouths to feed you have to
cook for more people you have to clean
all the time and they leave their junk
everywhere so you don't really have time
to power nap if you pound nap then the
house is going to be a tip or you're not
going to do that training all i'll say
is that while i don't want to downplay
the importance of sleep
you don't have to fret that much if you
only get six hours or even five hours a
few nights because this is a rite of
passage that every parent goes through
and it doesn't kill them the book why we
sleep by matthew walker actually makes
quite a lot of sweeping statements about
how a lack of sleep can double your
chances of cancer and all sorts of
things like that how it massively hurts
productivity increases injuries and
accidents and while there might be some
truth in this actually also found a
really interesting article online that
countered many of these points with
scientific literature saying that it's
not as clear-cut as we might think and
that's kind of like my gut impulse as
well because if that were true then
parents wouldn't live as long as
non-parents and actually we know that
the opposite is true parents live longer
than non-parents one of the reasons for
this might be because they pick up more
infections from preschool which actually
strengthens the immune system and for me
the worst thing i can do if i'm tired is
to fret about it make it into this big
issue especially if i hit the snooze
button if i lay around on the couch if i
tell people i'm tired conversely if i
just get to work smile put on some
upbeat music pretty quickly i forget
that i'm that tired and at the same time
if i'm moving throughout the days i've
talked about this is a great way to
stimulate yourself and provide yourself
with more energy as arnold
schwarzenegger himself would say sleep
quicker
in terms of productivity and achieving
the things you want to in business and
your career i will just say that once
again many of the same things apply you
need to focus on the essentials and then
just do the extra bit at the end of the
day if you have time that means for me
every week i have to make a video and
that's 100 the priority i don't even
really answer emails until that point
which means i do get some angry emails
later in the week that i have to deal
with but if i were to sit and answer
them and to write to-do lists and have
meetings with people who you know are
just gonna blow smoke then i wouldn't
really be being productive and i won't
be using my time maximally you want to
create a proper separation between work
and home but again being adaptable is
useful in this regard the right
technology can really help for instance
i just got a new laptop for editing on
the go it's made all the difference to
me we'll also say that you can multitask
again and in particular that means
planning whilst you're doing other stuff
so when i'm cooking when i'm on the
toilet i'll often be planning in my head
the next script the next video thinking
of all the different shots and i'll do
this for ages or listen to podcasts for
research or youtube videos for research
and i'll bring it all together so that
when it's time to film on monday i can
go straight into it and i know exactly
what i want to film
to step back and look at the bigger
picture you also need to be really clear
what your goals are and what you want
because think not only about the job in
terms of you know the glossy front of it
what you think it's going to be like but
also the day-to-day sure you might like
to be a powerful ceo who has lots of
influence and cool suits and a high-rise
building but then think about what
that's actually like what hours are
going to end up working is that
something you're happy to do as a parent
what's the commute like how stressful
would you be coming home i'd just like
to take a moment to make it really clear
that it's absolutely fine to not have
any big ambitions in terms of your
career etc there's this contingent on
the web that implies that if you're not
interested in becoming a movie star or a
business person or an entrepreneur then
you know you're wasting your time you're
never going to amount to anything and
your life doesn't matter etc i don't
think it's going to be further from the
truth there's absolutely nothing more
noble about being a movie star you know
an entrepreneur than there is if you
just want to have a nice life for your
family that's a perfectly fine
aspiration likewise it's perfectly fine
if you do want to change the world with
some kind of great ambition or idea just
keep in mind that you're not obligated
to be highly ambitious or to try and
change the world or do any of these
things and it's absolutely fine if
you're just happy ticking along and you
want to get your sense of meaning and
fulfillment from elsewhere finally i'd
say make sure you have your priorities
straight and that means not letting your
work bleed into your time with your kids
ultimately my big takeaway from all this
is that you can achieve all the things
you want to achieve in terms of your
fitness and your career and everything
else and you shouldn't view your family
as this kind of like big challenge to
overcome you just might need to adapt
some of the advice you've heard online
because so much of that is aimed
squarely at single 20-somethings very
few responsibilities and for a large
proportion of we youtube viewing public
that's simply not the reality hope you
found some useful tips in this video to
take away like i said i'd love to hear
your tips down below there's a lack of
advice for parents something that you've
noticed on youtube well there's some big
youtube channels that i'm missing this
video is a bit of a risk because i don't
know how many of you guys have kids that
would be interested in this topic and
i've ranted for ages but they're just
some points i really wanted to share and
hopefully some of you guys found it
interesting i'll be interested to see
how this video performs subscribe if you
want to see more like this and also not
that much like this and guys remember
that link in the description if you want
a seven day free trial of blinkist hit
the bell button for notifications and
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and i'll see you
next time
bye for now